Наддніпрянщина
Золотоноша
А чому називають цигани? Раніше називали.
Два слова є: "ци" і "ганга".
Слово "ци" означає "велика вода".
А "Ганга" - річка. Ви всі чули, у Індії є річка Ганга.
Імовірно, цигани там і були.
До війни, до 1941 року, тут цигани, тобто роми, не жили.
А зараз, знаєте, у нас тут дуже багато друзів в Золотоноші.
Я, як вийду на базар - то побачуся зі всіма своїми друзями.
Вони й до мене приїжджають щоб побачитися.
Сьогодні вкотре проводиться наша зустріч.
Це прийшли люди похилого віку.
Тут є і вчителі,
ветерани війни, є директори шкіл,
є й просто робочі.
Ці люди потребують таких зустрічей.
Вони розуміють, що ще комусь потрібні.
І що їхнє життя ще не закінчилось.
А так вони себе відчувають потрібними,
бадьорими, веселими.
Навіть коли людям по 82, по 92 роки.
Танцюють і співають.
Роми є кримські,
є кишинівці - молдавські,
є лаварі - це роми з Угорщини.
А є наші роми, українські, серви на них кажуть.
В кожних ромів - свій діалект.
Є такі цигани, які мову один одного не можуть зрозуміти.
Якщо ми тут всі сидимо україномовні,
ми навіть свою мову дуже погано знаємо.
Декілька слів може хто, а молодь зовсім не знає своєї мови.
Забули...
Раніше цигани ходили накривати хати,
чоловіки ходили.
Ну піди, побалакай по-циганськи до тієї людини, вона тебе не зрозуміє: чорний циган,
ще й балакає незрозуміло.
Треба навчитися української мови.
У 1971 році у Великобританії пройшов перший з'їзд ромів,
циган.
Раніше, до цього, в кожній країні, де жили цигани - їх по-різному називали.
Наприклад в Україні й Росії на нас казали "цигани".
В Середній Азії казали "люль".
В Індії казали "доме".
В Англії казали "джипсі".
І от у кожній країні називали по-різному.
І от на цьому з'їзді перше, що було прийнято,
щоб називати циган одним словом - "роми".
"Ром" - означає "ти циганський син".
А в Індії є Бог Рама такий,
то це й означає "ти син Бога Рами".
Це не стовідсотково, але є така версія.
А пам'ятаєте, як циган Антон грав на гармошці?
Так грав, що, розповідали, всидіти було неможливо.
Одного разу приїхали якісь артисти з області.
І квитки там продають, в зал заходять.
Він каже, що грав, як завжди - перед фільмами чи перед концертами.
Ну він сів та й грає на гармошці,
а потім уже треба заходити до зали.
Всі зайшли до зали, хто з квитками, а він - гармошку під руку і теж йде до зали.
А там контролер стояв, каже, давай квиток.
А Антон каже - я ж тут працюю.
А контролер не пускає. Антон говорить - мене як розізлило!
Образився, сів, та як заграв!
То вистава не почалася, люди повиходили з залу і давай танцювати!
Вистава зривається, а я, каже, граю!
Підходить той контролер, каже - заходь, дорогий,
а Антон каже - ні, і грає далі.
Каже, десь годину грав з тієї злості.
Практично весь зал вийшов, всі танцюють.
Тоді контролер підходить, вже ледь не плаче, каже - ти ж зриваєш нам виставу!
Заходь у залу! Ну добре, каже Антон,
взяв гармошку і пішов у залу.
Циган пройшов,
пройшов вулицею циган - уже бояться,
уже щось циган зробив - украде, уб'є.
А свого вони не помічають, наприклад, ну не дай Бог,
якби показали по телебаченню, що циган там когось
побив чи щось зробив погане.
То це обов'язково все місто буде шуміти.
Базаром пройти неможливо.
"Он ваші цигани отаке роблять".
Вся увага переключається на нас.
Один зробив, а всі винні.
Вирішив я зібрати більшість ромів
щоб зробити общину.
Зареєстрували організацію в 2001 році, на початку.
І почали діяти.
Отут, і тут - всюди живуть роми.
І тут теж роми живуть.
Ми робимо центр "Діалог між поколіннями".
Оце в нас тут взимку, хто не приходить,
тут часто люди туляться. У нас є газ.
Але ми, для романтики, запалюємо піч.
Я вас серйозно кажу, приходять і фотографують пічку, селфі роблять.
Молодь...
Планували цей центр не лише для ромів.
Він ромський, та ми публікували і в пресі,
і говоримо - сюди може прийти будь-хто.
Будь-хто може отримати якесь,
медичного характеру,
обстеження.
Призначення якесь. Ну, ви знаєте, зараз сімейні лікарі.
Це треба декларації заповнювати.
От ми заповнюємо тут
і люди вже знають куди прийти щоб отримати першу медичну довідку якусь.
А потім вже медик його направляє далі.
Я себе вважаю українцем
ромського походження.
Так само би всі себе вважали
і відносили так.
Так само, як є українець з Західної України і зі Східної України.
Він українець і ми всі українці.
І нам потрібно будувати одну державу і один будинок для себе.
(співають гімн України)
Слава Україні!
Героям Слава!
І на віки слава!
А хіба цигани - це не український народ?
Український.
Ну так а чого ти з пісні слова викидаєш?